- [Voiceover] Hello, grammarians,
and, hello, Paige.
- [Voiceover] Hi, David.
- [Voiceover] So, what
are we working on today?
- [Voiceover] So, today
we're gonna talk about
the difference between it's and its.
- [Voiceover] Oh, oh,
that sounds real tricky.
- [Voiceover] Yeah, but we'll be okay.
- [Voiceover] Okay.
So, it's, with an apos--
So, we have these two forms in English
and they mean very different things.
So, let's go though them really quick.
So, it's with an apostrophe
is a contraction, right?
What is it a contraction of?
- [Voiceover] It is or it has.
- [Voiceover] As in, it's
a lovely day outside.
Or, for it has, like it's been,
it has been one week since
you looked at cheese.
- [Voiceover] (laughing)
Sad, it's been a sad week.
- [Voiceover] It's been a sad week.
As opposed to its.
Can you walk me through its.
- [Voiceover] So, its
is a possessive pronoun.
And it's a little
confusing 'cause possessive
usually uses an apostrophe, too.
But possessive pronouns
don't use apostrophes.
So, you would say something like,
I like rib-eye steak
because of its rich flavor.
- [Voiceover] That's a
pretty grody-looking steak.
- [Voiceover] (laughs) I
know, pink and green is
not how you want your steak to look.
- [Voiceover] So, we frankly just used
its where we would use his
or her or their or our.
You would use its.
- [Voiceover] Right, it's just
that it's not a person, so.
- [Voiceover] So, if I were asking you,
can I borrow your book?
That's kinda the same thing as
I like rib-eye steak
because of its flavor.
- [Voiceover] Right, it's showing that
the flavor belongs to the steak
just like the book belongs to me.
- [Voiceover] Right.
So, flavor belongs to it,
book belongs to you.
So, this is the core distinction,
is if you're talking about anything
that would be about
possession you use its.
I-T-S, no apostrophe.
If you're trying to contract something,
it is or it has, like
it's a lovely day outside
or it's been one week
since you looked at cheese.
Then you would use I-T apostrophe S
'cause it's a contraction,
you're trying to
cram more information into
this one little phrase.
- [Voiceover] Precisely.
- [Voiceover] Sweet.
That's how you choose
between I-T apostrophe S
and I-T no apostrophe S.
You can learn anything.
David out.
- [Voiceover] Paige out.